so now we start on a new unit called
counting or combinatorics and it's about
counting things now one of the things
that happens when you're counting is you
typically adding up a bunch of numbers
that you've counted along the way and so
you wind up needing to deal with sums a
lot and so let's start with those
mathematical preliminaries we're going
to look at three kinds of sums
arithmetic sums geometric sums and
harmonic sums all of which come up very
regularly and they will have reasonably
nice formulas that explain what they sum
to let's begin with the simplest ones of
arithmetic sums so there's an example
this supposedly is the kind of problem
that was assigned to children in the
night in the 18th century to keep them
busy in class and the great
mathematician Gauss carl friedrich gauss
you know from magnetism and from
probability theory but also in fact the
inventor of congruence and and the
number theory that we've studied showed
his brilliance as a child prodigy when
he was nine years old supposedly he
noticed that in that chart of numbers
that we just saw there were 30 numbers
and each one was 13 greater than the
previous one the idea being that the
tutor didn't want to go through the
effort of summing everything up
he knew the trick to get the sum quickly
but he kept his students busy for hours
doing that kind of problem I don't know
and that this is a true story or not but
it's a good story so let's go on with it
so in other words what Gauss noticed was
that the numbers on that page looked
like 89 and 89 plus 13 down through the
30th number 89 plus 29 times 13 and then
he saw how to get the sum of a the the
simple expression for the value of this
sum and the logic is that let's call the
first term F and then the next term is F
plus 2 DF plus D or D is 13 and F is 89
next one would be F plus 2 D down to the
end and I'm gonna call the last term L
which is 89 plus 29 times 13 this would
be L minus D or 89 times plus 28 times 3
and let's call that some a we don't know
what it is yet but look very quickly
gonna derive it and one of the standard
tricks to find nice formulas for sums is
to find a arithmetic relation between
the sum and it's like perturbation of
the sum in this case I'm just gonna
write the sum backwards so it's the same
sum a but written where the first term
is last and the last term is first and
now notice what happens when I add up
these two sums I get to weigh of course
but every one of these terms this is an
F plus L this is an F plus D plus L
minus T it's F plus L this last one is
an F plus L every one of these pairwise
some sub sums comes out to be F plus L
and now we have a formula for the whole
series a nice simple formula that a is
equal to the sum of the first term plus
the last term divided by two times the
number of terms by the way the first
term plus the last time divided by two
is maybe is more memorable if you
remember that it's the average term it's
the average size term times the number
of terms and that's how you sum up an
arithmetic sum so we can wrap up with a
familiar example namely the sum of the
integers from 1 to N this is an
arithmetic series starts with 1 and the
D that is the difference from successive
terms is simply 1 1 1 plus 1 1 1 plus 1
plus 1 down to n and according to our
formula it's the first plus the last
over 2 times the number of terms and we
have that familiar formula for the sum
of the first n integers